hello and welcome to the reason live
stream I'm Zach Weissmuller and I'm
joined today by my colleague Nick
Gillespie hey Nick
hey
good to see you too uh today we're
talking with Jacob Siegel uh a
journalist with tablet magazine to
discuss his quite remarkable piece on
what he's termed the counter
disinformation complex it is a long and
detailed essay entitled a guide to
understanding The hoax of the century 13
ways of looking at disinformation I mean
it connects to a lot of the themes we've
talked about on this show about social
media myths and disinformation the
process of the government job owning
companies and to policing speech and the
ways that would-be Gatekeepers are
trying to reassert control over the flow
of information in this country this
essay lays out our current predicament
in a really compelling and comprehensive
way and offers some much needed
historical context as well that we'll
get into into this conversation and I'm
very excited to discuss it with Jacob
today thank you so much for joining us
yeah I'm excited too thanks for having
me
so uh it's a guide to understanding The
hoax of the century let's just start
with that title what is the hoax of the
century
The hoax is the the false claim and I
would argue the deliberately false claim
that the United States and indeed uh all
liberal democracies are under a dire
existential threat from disinformation
and disinformation needs to be explained
here if uh if indeed
um you know our survival is imperiled by
disinformation it's it's worth taking a
moment to consider what that thing is
and in its original form disinformation
was supposed to be a kind of targeted
attack by hostile foreign entities who
infiltrated the media ecosystems and the
social ecosystems of Western liberal
democracies the United States obviously
during the 25th uh 2015-2016 campaign
and election but also Great Britain
during brexit uh similar arguments were
made there and so this was hostile
foreign entities notably Russia
infiltrating these societies with
deliberately false and deceptive
information
disinformation the the titular
disinformation that was so dangerous in
the way it undermined the foundations of
electoral legitimacy and liberal
democracy itself that it required a a
wartime response and a wartime
mobilization meaning the suspension of
due process of constitutional rights and
protections and the giving over of the
political system itself to security
agencies and their adjuncts within the
administrative bureaucracy so that they
could protect us from this
disinformation threat which was you know
like more dangerous than terrorism
because it was everywhere at once coming
in through our very screens and and
iPhones and so all of this constitutes
The hoax because there was no grave
threat from disinformation let alone a
existential threat that justified the
sort of state of exception that was used
to fundamentally re-engineer the
political system in the United States
which is what took place
and I want to get into how that all
happened uh the the recent history and
then the deeper history but first before
I kick it to Nick for a second uh I want
to pull up an excerpt from the article
to really Linger on this term
disinformation you write a name as a
nation America not only has learned
nothing it has been deliberately
prevented from learning anything while
being made to chase after Shadows this
is not because Americans are stupid it's
because what has taken place is not a
tragedy but something closer to a crime
disinformation is both the name of the
crime and the means of covering it up a
weapon that doubles as a disguise could
you just expand on that a little bit
what is the utility of the term
disinformation to push forward a sort of
new system of governance is kind of what
you're arguing in this piece
well it's a term that both evokes threat
and danger as uh as fits its origins in
the world of Espionage and the Cold War
while at the same time implicitly
encoded in the term is
um that there is a deception that
something is being veiled or obscured
and so the the word is simply confusing
and threatening at the same time and so
it is not an accident that this
information is a term that is basically
impossible to Define in any meaningful
way when you try and when you try and
delimit what are the categories of
information that count as disinformation
it's basically anything that is uh
counter to the prevailing
um you know official sort of uh ruling
party narrative at any given time is
this information so to use real examples
of this and and for anybody who thinks I
might be uh being hyperbolic here you
know one day it could be disinformation
to say that
um you know to question vaccine efficacy
in terms of whether or not vaccines
transmit excuse me whether or not
vaccines prevent the transmission of uh
covid that could count as disinformation
if it was uh supposedly being incited if
that claim was being incited or
perpetuated by Foreign act or
misinformation if it was merely domestic
actors of their own accord making that
claim
um Mal information once it turned out to
be true and yet was still in some sense
undermining the the you know hygienic
policies of this state so disinformation
is
um literally has has changed
day-to-day based on sort of what suits
the ruling party at any given time and
the word itself the the sort of
recursive quality of the word itself
where you get caught inside this riddle
of what is this information is I think
part of the point and it's not an
accident that's such a confusing term
was born in the world of Espionage and
this is something that America's leading
security uh Cold War security officials
warned about for decades George Cannon
I'm talking about hardcore
anti-communist cold Warriors George
Kennan Daniel Patrick Moynihan were
warning for decades that the growth of
the secrecy bureaucracy within the
United States government and the
normalization and spread of the tactics
of Espionage which we're going as the
Cold War went on we're going from being
these specialized tools of a specialized
Cadre of spies and security officials
and becoming the sort of operating
procedures of you know
non-uh foreign facing government
agencies that as this occurred the
confusions and Illusions inherent in
those systems of spying and Espionage
and deception were going to poison a
political system in the United States
that's supposed to be based on
transparency and self-government
uh let's talk a little bit about the
2016 election and maybe into the into
2020 and and the rise of the covet
regime and whatnot
um and then you know towards the end of
the uh of of our time together we're
going to talk more about the Cold War
roots and kind of look back at you know
what happened in post-war America that
kind of put this all into play
um when you talk about the ruling party
um you're not talking about the
Democrats or the Republicans you're
talking about a uh broader conception of
a kind of elite consensus or a
managerial consensus could you talk a
little bit about that you know and say
going into the 2016 election
um you know and it seems so far ago it's
not you know it obviously isn't that
long ago but it already seems that and
some of the big issues that got wrapped
up in this revolved around the I the
revelations that Hillary Clinton have
been keeping as Secretary of State have
been keeping a private email server and
was kind of sloppy in terms of you know
what what were personal emails and what
were you know actual official emails uh
but then also the dnc's emails got uh
got hacked or you know and and it turns
out it was I guess John podesta had
answered a phishing uh you know query
and things came out what so two
questions first in going into 2016 what
was that ruling party you're talking
about kind of suss out what that what
comprises that and then let's talk a
little bit about the specific moments of
disinformation that people think changed
the outcome of the 2016 election
the ruling party
um in a sense is less important than the
ruling class in America I would argue
and I don't say that to be pedantic but
you know the United States because of
how its structured has never had a a
single ruling party in the way that
other states and political systems are
designed around the idea of a ruling
party China has a ruling party we can
all recognize that in the United States
what you had was the emergence of a a
ruling class which had members and
representatives in both of the major
political parties the Democrats and the
Republicans I think you know famously I
forget who said who said it when there
was Angela code Villa but the the
Republicans were the sort of junior
members of the ruling party so they
could belong but had a sort of
second-tier role but the ruling class in
the United States is a function of
forces of centralization that really
accelerate in the second half of the
20th century and lead to these
hyper-consolidated you know Coastal
enclaves and uh DC Corridor and this
emergence of a single National
monoculture among the credentialed
members of a ruling class who share a
set of customs and who share a set of
educational credentials and underlying
all that share some foundational
premises but before getting to those
premises it's important to distinguish
how that's different from the regional
aristocracies and Regional Elites that
have always existed in the United States
and and have existed essentially
everywhere at all times so of course the
US always you know there was a southern
Gentry in the U.S there were
Northeastern manufacturing and financial
Elites there were uh you know railroad
uh and and other
um industry and and developer
um uh Elites and and uh and uh
oligarchic uh you know there were
periods of oligarchic control at other
points in American history but they had
a a regional basis that meant that they
did not act in concert with one another
across the country and meant that they
were both responsive to some of the uh
regional and local concerns and were
themselves in their own Tendencies and
orientation uh were themselves molded by
those Regional cultures with The
Disappearance of the regional culture
and the emergence of a national
monoculture in the United States and you
know these are not simply cultural
trends that I'm describing there's an
underlying political economic reality to
this where we're talking about the
consolidation of wealth and of capital
and we're talking about the uh these
sort of national credentialing
institutions becoming the most important
institutions in the country you get this
single kind of Monolithic ruling class
and
um that ruling class is then represented
by the ruling party in the United States
and the ruling party is the
constellation
of agencies and party apparatuses with
both Republican and Democratic
representation but also crucially spread
across the nominally
non-partisan non-party Affiliated
Federal bureaucracies and indeed across
other institutions that are not even
officially part of the federal
government but function as the uh
function as the sort of
either in the non-profit and NGO sector
um or in the universities to some extent
function as sort of extensions of this
ruling party and so to put this in very
concrete terms what does this mean it
means a coordinated uh effort by uh one
group of people in Americans to declare
a monopoly over the political system it
means that when somebody you don't like
gets elected like Donald Trump somebody
who's threatening to your interests and
I should say there are many many reasons
one could dislike Donald Trump and could
strenuously and
um you know vociferously object to his
presidency the difference between that
kind of political opposition and the
ruling party is twofold one it's the
degree of consensus across the the
ruling class and and it's the use of the
federal agencies the use of the federal
bureaucracy in order to delegitimize an
elected president Donald Trump and the
way that this works where there is a
sort of
spontaneously emerging consensus bottom
up on the one hand which is the cultural
consensus among members of the ruling
class nobody needs to tell them Donald
Trump is uh is an ogre is an existential
threat they all feel this viscerally so
there's that element but that's met at
the same time by a top-down coordinated
effort across the agencies and we see
this with the FBI quite plainly we see
this with the uh people inside of the
FBI who are you know working on the
Trump investigation while exchanging
texts about how they're going to protect
democracy by keeping him from getting
elected we see this with the Jim Baker
who was the uh one of the lead councils
at the FBI leaving that job to then take
a job as a deputy lead council at
Twitter just in time so that when the
hunter laptop Hunter Biden laptop uh
story began to emerge he was in place as
the deputy council at Twitter so that he
could advise the company against uh you
know advise the company to go along with
the the you know requests uh mandates
essentially from the FBI that they not
publicize the story so that's the that
is the ruling party
um right and so it it is not simply
people in the media Elite the
academically the cultural Elite uh you
know certainly you know uh economy
whether it's Silicon Valley or
industrial stuff saying I'm really mad
that Donald Trump got elected it is that
Donald Trump's election represents an
existential threat to America to the
American experiment and also often comes
with either implications or or you know
flat out statements that the only way he
could have been elected was through a
manipulation of the American political
system with disinformation and things
like that yeah all of that plus then
um because the the sort of corollary a
conclusion of that is because he
represents this existential threat
because he himself used illegitimate
means to get elected disinformation
collusion with Vladimir Putin therefore
it is legitimate for US representatives
of the ruling party right to suspend the
normal rules of liberal democracy of
procedural uh government suspend those
normal official rules enter into the
state of exception where we can spy on
the president you know where we can uh
push through collude between federal
agencies and private partisan actors
like Perkins koi and fusion GP us who
are the sort of Brokers of the phony
steel dossier in order to feed that to
the FBI so that we can then feed that
into the fisa warrant process so we can
obtain a warrant to spy on the president
of the United States and the members of
his campaign we can break all of these
rules for two reasons and I don't think
you can actually separate these reasons
out I mean I don't think the people
doing this could separate these reasons
out they could not separate out the
illegitimacy the sort of absolute
illegitimacy of Donald Trump on the one
hand in the way in which he was a threat
to America and their steel unbreakable
conviction that anybody who is not one
of them
um was a kind of existential threat in
that way and and again this uh I mean
we'll talk about this later this has uh
premonitions in the Cold War and the way
the political discourse uh you know kind
of was enacted in cultural discourse but
it's not just that they have a
legitimate right to do this they almost
have a responsibility
um because otherwise everything's going
down the tubes and they they have to you
you've uh used the term state of
exception a couple times uh that is a
phrase that is you know best uh known or
most popular is by Giorgio agambin the
Italian philosopher who talked about
that uh you know who came to prominence
after the 9 11 bombings when he talked
about how the suspension of civil rights
in the global war on terror was deemed
necessary in order to preserve a free
society and so he uh pulling off of Carl
Schmidt the Nazi German philosopher who
talked about how liberal democracies
were particularly prone to morphing into
kind of authoritarian states he said and
I think with great power that um you
know the the state is almost always
looking for a reason to declare a state
of exception and the irony of it or the
Paradox of it is in order to save a free
Society we have to suspend all of the
rules that allow it to be a free Society
in order to preserve it
um are you pulling off of a gambin you
know uh specifically there and can you
articulate a little bit more about
um you know do states of exception there
they don't necessarily get uh declared
in Congress or in the Press I mean they
can sometimes but oftentimes it's a
consensus that is kind of under the wire
right
yeah I think the thing that gets
declared by Congress and the Press is
the existential threat so they by once
you've sufficiently trumpeted the direct
threat and you've cleared that anybody
would participate in
defense against that excess threat is
them now an enemy in the Midian sense of
a friend enemy distinction right
they trumpet the threat and the state of
exception takes care of
right I wasn't I was not drawing
explicitlyn uh comes from with his work
um especially familiar with post covid
work they were sort of brought him
I think a public attention made him a
pariah among the very people we've uh
talked about this on this program and
elsewhere among the very people who were
you know when he talked about it in
terms of 9 11 they were like yes this is
exactly right and then when covet hit
and he's Italian and he was living in
Italy and he said you know what this is
a socially constructed pandemic and
panic so that the state can declare a
state of exception and in many cases his
particularly his you know left-wing
academic followers in the U.S literally
said you you are nuts you are crazy you
are insane
um yet the analysis works pretty well in
both both instances
isn't that yeah I think it's a
fascinating question why that occurred
why why you know you could see the same
thing with sort of uh grad student
foucaians who became the most Ardent
embracers of the bio surveillance State
yeah after
um after covet emerged then to give a
very short answer to what I think is a
complicated and thorny question it seems
to me that it's less about hypocrisy and
more about the fact that for most people
their political beliefs are a kind of
uh and an epiphenomenon of their
relationship to power and it's like when
you're close to the you know in the army
they say you know you want to be near
the flagpole right and it's like people
want to be near the flagpole and and
when their party is in power they
justify what their party's doing and and
um and uh but I think it's it's also a
testament to how powerful the gambin's
um critique and and ideas were that
they've become state of exception feels
to me like it's just uh a sort of phrase
floating you know anybody could grab it
out of the discourse at this point
there was uh it one thing I really
appreciate about this article was that a
lot of the analysis around
what's come out from the Twitter files
uh you know Russia gate in general the
hunter Biden laptop is it tends to be on
the media layer which is important and
the media plays a big role in
defining threats and whether you know
the scope of weather disinformation and
misinformation is a threat and a lot of
major Outlets have certainly leaned into
that in fact you uh pulled up little
Montage here of uh articles that you
know show Donald Trump won because of
Facebook Facebook and crosshairs after
election is uh uh is said to questions
influence Russian propaganda effort
helps spread fake news during election
experts say but on the other hand
um you know you make the case that
they the media is actually not the
primary mover or culprit here and that
it's uh you you dive into
the role that let's say intelligence
analysts and agencies have have played
in pushing this idea that misinformation
and disinformation is an existential
threat that needs some sort of dramatic
intervention and I want to pull up a
clip from one of the most prominent
purveyors of that idea and one of the
people who we saw on TV a lot throughout
the discussion about Russian
interference in the 2016 election and
that's former CIA director John Brennan
I just like to play this clip and get
your reaction to this clip and you tell
me what you think
statements like this from the former CIA
director how they affected the
conversation around these issues hey and
can I just pipe it I just want to say
before we start not all Irish Americans
not all Irish Americans but let's let's
run this Brennan clip okay
happy to have with us former CIA
director John Brennan who is now an NBC
News senior National Security and
intelligence analyst why won't the
president confront Vladimir Putin why
won't he read the cards and say the
things that you say need to be said to
Vladimir Putin do you believe he's
somehow in debt to the president of
Russia I think he's afraid of the
president of Russia why um well I think
one can speculate as to why that the
Russians may have something on him
personally that they could always roll
out and make his life more difficult
what's your reaction to that in
retrospect knowing what we know now
well first of all I did command a rifle
company in the Fighting Irish fighting
69th Infantry Regiment so I am an
honorary Irishman myself and
um
yeah I have two reactions and I I will
get to the disinformation thing in a
second but the first thing I'll say to
come back to the question of the ruling
party is that the the sort of tricked
understanding how the ruling party
operates in America is that
it is because it is uh run by the
perhaps the most untalented incompetent
group of people ever assembled in the
country's history that they have
insisted on such a
um insisted on these coercive and
monopolistic tactics for controlling the
government I mean I think Brennan is a
um but by the the sort of the standard
measures of what you would expect from
the nation's intelligence Chief
phenomenally untalented and
unaccomplished where he has excelled is
as a party hack you know as a as a a
Soviet or Chinese style party hack and
the claim that he is making there which
is that Donald Trump is controlled by or
indebted to or or somehow under the
thumb of Vladimir Putin and therefore by
extension the Russian Security Services
is a claim that he is in many senses
singularly responsible for entering into
the official record of American politics
when in one of his last acts the CIA
chief he basically
singularly orchestrated what was known
as the ICA the intelligence Community
assessment so this was the I believe it
came out in January 2017 but it was the
first the seminal
intelligence Community assessment which
declared that not only did Putin
interfere in the 2016 election but that
he had a preference for Donald Trump
what we later found out through
Classified house testimony
um that you know people who had been
privy to it spoke about was that rather
than being a a statement on representing
the opinion of the 17 different
intelligence agencies which is what an
ICA is supposed to be a consensus
statement in other words that in fact
Brennan himself had hand-picked a group
of analysts and had personally uh led
the drafting of the ICA that declared
that Putin had a preference for Trump
and that in doing so he had excluded the
analysis from Russia experts who not
only didn't find that credible but who
said that no in fact as Russia experts
they had found that Putin's preference
was actually for Hillary Clinton because
uh Putin considered her the more
predictable candidate not that there was
any nefarious relationship with Clinton
but simply that in ways that are quite
easy to understand that he he wanted the
sort of stock neoliberal candidate
because he could guess what move she was
going to make and so that that was
Brennan's doing
um Brennan you know the fact that he
left the CIA to immediately become a
MSNBC analyst tells you a lot both about
Brennan and about MSNBC and the
relationship between the media and the
intelligent agencies and the media here
is simply providing the amplification
system
for narratives that are originating
elsewhere you know that's why I I talk
about the weakness of the media in
relation to these other members of the
counter disinformation complex not
because the media doesn't play a
critical role in amplifying and
enforcing these narratives but because
it doesn't generate these narratives on
its own and therefore it's not in charge
of their final Direction and orientation
okay so I may uh just I I would like to
point out that morning Joe is kind of
like the Max's Kansas City or The Studio
54 of the ruling party right this is
It's you know not accidental that this
happened and on MSNBC and on NBC News
and things like that so when you are
when you observe this fact pattern uh
around John Brennan and see that he he
discarded certain information and
privileged other information is is
making these very
pointed well not pointed but let's say
very broad speculation on National
Television is your analysis that this is
a kind of tunnel vision
um that he can he he believes this or
that this actually is something more
nefarious that this is that it that he's
trying to actually be a disinformation
purveyor
well two things so one I would never
accuse somebody of being a
disinformation purveyor because I don't
use the term in that way I think the
term is deliberately obscuritanist and
it's an Espionage term and I'm I'm not
in the business of Espionage so I'm not
accusing anybody of disinformation I
think I think they get things wrong or
they get them right
um
I look I don't see any reason to try and
impute motive here I think that the the
facts of the case speak for themselves
what we know about The Crafting of the
ICA is that Brennan omitted contrary
analysis and you should people should go
back and read that ICA from 2017 when I
when I talk about how untalented he is
you know I think sometimes the documents
speak louder than these
characterizations go read the ICA it it
establishes nothing it proves nothing
it's not well argued it has a 12-page
appendix drawing on Russia Today
articles from 2012. it's like a a shoddy
nomenclatura kind of document that is a
sort of placeholder Brennan's
willingness to or or interest in
transitioning from the CIA to talking
ahead on on MSNBC to signatory to the
false National Security official little
documents claiming that the hunter Biden
laptops were disinformation
um speaks for itself he's remarkably
consistent on these issues he's very
close uh I think to the people in the
Obama World closer than he is to the
people in the Clinton world for instance
so he has clear
um
he has clear party connections which are
more important here than ideological uh
ideological convictions you know it's
like a late Soviet thing not an early
Soviet thing this is not what what a
terrible thing to say to anybody that
they're not even a peak Soviet faction
no no it's it's not Peak Soviet it's you
know it's like it's
redneb when he let himself go right it's
not even trimming his eyebrows so let me
uh to extend this a little bit more uh
you know one of the things when I was
you know obviously we all lived through
this but then watching that clip again
and preparing for this it's also to me
it's just staggering it in the Press uh
you know in this amplification process
like you know the Press didn't have
Richard Helms on after you know when it
came out that former CIA director who
had burned you know had ordered burned
tons of documents that would have shown
what the CIO was doing it wasn't like he
showed up in a couple weeks on uh on CBS
News or NBC or ABC and was Pals with
people and they were like oh that's so
fascinating like you are a speaker of
Truth there the the kind of righteous
antagon antagonism between the press and
government officials in many cases and
this goes to kind of trying to
understand the way the ruling class kind
of functions you know that you know the
the Press will say we're the Watchdog of
Freedom you know democracy dies in
darkness all of that kind of stuff but
in fact they suck up to power and they
kind of just repeat or amplify many of
their claims without any uh you know
critical uh analysis whatsoever and
let's uh Zach let's look at the clip
that you pulled and this is related to
this in a kind of New Media intellectual
you know kind of cloud
um people like Sam Harris the very you
know who is part of the intellect
lectural dark web once it's Once Upon a
Time and now has a phenomenally uh
popular podcast uh speaks to a lot of
people you know who used to oh he used
to only talk about being an atheist and
now he talks about being a psychonaut
and being a meditator and also being you
know a wise vision of you know
existential threats to democracy
um let's run a clip of an interview with
him with some uh uh British uh blokes I
think or the the people behind
trigonometry
um and then Jacob would you comment on
the mindset that is being Advanced by
Sam Harris in this discussion of why it
was a great goddamn good thing that
Twitter and Facebook suppressed the
hunter Biden laptop story in the run-up
to the 2020 election
so so my argument is that it was
appropriate for Twitter
and the heads of big Tech and journal
and the heads of journalistic
organizations to feel that they were in
the presence of something like a a once
in a lifetime moral emergency right
whereas this is not the same thing as
not liking George Bush
you know or not liking John McCain or
not liking Mitt Romney for their
politics this was here's a guy who
is capable of anything and we cannot
afford to have four more years with this
guy right and and so
um
so what what should
well-intentioned people do who have a
lot of power in these various ways you
know you're running the New York Times
you're running CNN you're running
Twitter
what should they've conspire to do what
do you do with the hunter Biden laptop
story
when we already know we we know how this
played out in 2016 with the Hillary
Clinton email you know press conference
that was the killing blow to her
candidacy it's like a coin toss for me
the hunter Biden laptop thing because I
I do understand how
corrosive it is
for an institution like the the New York
Times to show obvious bias and
inconsistency and dishonesty in how they
it's like they couldn't even frame it
honestly it's not like it's not like
it's like the way I would frame it is uh
listen I don't care what's in Hunter
Biden's I mean a hunter Biden at that
point Hunter Biden literally could have
had the corpses of children in his
basement I would not have cared right
it's like it's there's nothing first of
all it's Hunter Biden right it's not
it's like it's not Joe Biden but even if
Joe like even whatever scope of Joe
Biden's corruption is like if you if we
could just go down that rabbit hole
endlessly and and understand that he's
getting kickbacks from Hunter and
Biden's deals in Ukraine or whatever
else right or China
it is
infinitesimal
compared to the corruption we know Trump
is involved in
yeah well I listen I'm thankful uh
genuinely grateful to Sam Harris for um
he just he lines up so many
um corrupt and and
fallacious ideas in a row and I think
very usefully
and this is where you know I I think he
does a real
um Public Service there is he usefully
shows the interrelation between these
various kinds of
um fallacious and and I think
destructive thinking so to take this
from the top
um here here is a person Sam Harris
whose whole career and reputation was
built on being a sort of human truth
Optimizer right his whole career was
that he was the dispassionate objective
the the the one who couldn't be swayed
by primitive and atavistic beliefs in
God or or
um you know an intrinsic uh moral
component in existence he was above all
of those things and what it means in
Practical terms to be above all of those
things
um is to be precisely the kind of
technocratic Judge of the good that
Harris makes himself here now not
everybody not every atheist takes this
as far as Harris does obviously but
um I do think that it is not an accident
that the that the same Sam Harris
who made his name as the great truth
engine is the the human truth machine is
now very flippantly saying it doesn't
matter what the truth is what matters is
the greater good which of course he is
in he isn't in the position to decide
not the American public or voters no Sam
Harris can tell you Sam Harris has
decided that it doesn't matter what's on
Hunter Biden's laptops it doesn't matter
that Twitter and Facebook censored and
repressed this what matters is that he
recognizes the grave danger of Donald
Trump so here we have a very important
connection which is the connection
between the kind of underlying let's
call it the the sort of metaphysical
layer of the technocratic mind which he
is a supreme representative of on the
one end and the oligarchic ruling party
certainty that it is in the best
position to decide whose votes should
count whose votes shouldn't count what
information can be seen what information
can't be seen
um so I don't think you you should look
at this and think ah Sam Harris great
truth secret Sam Harris as being a
hypocrite here I don't think it's
hypocrisy I think it's a cop to call
that hypocrisy no that is a perfectly
consistent position for Sam Harris to
take and this is you know what was the
Lenin call it like Imperial the highest
form of imperialism this is the highest
form of technocracy the highest form of
the technocratic Mind Sam Harris is the
Supreme representative the technocratic
minds and
it's also worth thinking about if this
was true if Trump was indeed the danger
that Sam Harris and others are
suggesting he was to Justified
everything why did they have to keep
lying about him
why did they have to make up all these
stories does he does Sam Harris not know
that the steel dossier was nothing but a
compendium of totally constructed this
sourced to Washington DC Think Tank
employees much of the nonsense Lucio
dossier didn't
you know
through
the function
I'm not aware of
I mean so
they couldn't probably say Trump is a
very bad he's a very bad pre not fit by
the white house uh he is a honors this
country
um he's a racist he's a nativist you
know there's truth in all of equipments
I just you might not agree with them
fully but enough truth that you could
possibly argue about those
president in America but even if you say
he's
in American history that's still
to
by
justify the unilateral mention of
Constable protect around free speech and
and privacy
so
it's enough this president ever had to
be
singular Central threat because that
alone fought party exercising such
Powers were necessary to maintain
Monopoly
we're getting a little bit of
interference there on on your end uh
Jacob the it's lagging a little bit but
uh we got most of that uh you know the
the technocratic aspect is worth
I think uh lingering on for a second
because that is really what's this
these technological systems have now
enabled
the platforms and the people pressuring
the platforms to believe that they can
really track these Trends to a extremely
precise level and then like dial things
up and down in order to improve the
discourse or keep people from getting
hurt I mean I think we saw this amped up
uh post pandemic or really like reached
the next level uh in the cobit era but
when during the during the the Russia
gate era there was this project uh
Hamilton 68 and I've pulled aside from
their dashboard uh all the links to this
is an archived version and we we have a
link in the description and it shows you
know these are the top hashtags that uh
you know Russian related or Russian
influenced accounts are tweeting out and
uh just to this is the little disc
claimer they put on the dashboard that
the charts and graphs here display
hashtags topics URLs promoted by Russian
linked influence networks on Twitter
content is not necessarily produced or
created by Russian government operatives
although that is sometimes the case
you know let me let me jump in there for
one second because it's a it's important
with that disclaimer okay so they had a
disclaimer on the site saying these are
not all directly linked to Russia but
Clint Watts the former FBI agent who was
the figurehead of Hamilton 68 also wrote
a op-ed essentially an article in The
Daily Beast or co-wrote an article in
The Daily Beast in 2016 that was very
influential in establishing kind of
narrative framework of Russian
disinformation in which he explicitly
argues that there is a convergence
between Russian troll accounts and
official Russian disinformation accounts
and trumpkins as he calls right he says
that they're becoming indistinguishable
so this the the disclaimer on the
Hamilton 68 uh site is fine as far as it
goes and establishing some degree of I
guess what's intended to be a kind of uh
protection from legal liability in cases
of defamation but it's it's belied by
the argument of its own figurehead who
wrote explicitly that trumpkins whether
winning or not whether deliberately
acting as fellow Travelers or not have
become indistinguishable from Russian uh
operatives spreading deliberate
disinformation
and to be clear that that you know that
this was one of the revelations from the
Twitter files is that the social media
the the kind of safety in content
moderation team recognized that the
methodology behind this was totally
messed up and uh Joel Roth I think was
saying like we got to call this [__]
out and they never did
um but I mean do you think that this had
any measurable effect on the discourse
uh just just having something like this
out there kind of watching waiting to
tag people with the you know
russian-linked
propaganda meme
I think it had a very significant impact
as a additional layer of girding
in this larger
narrative structure
which was propagating the idea that the
U.S was under attack from Russian
disinformation and that your fellow
citizens with whom you disagreed were no
longer merely fellow citizens
um but should be seen as extensions of
Nefarious illegitimate hostile forces so
how many people's minds were I mean look
I'm sure it was a very big deal for the
people who were getting smeared by this
I don't want to to minimize that but I
don't think that Hamilton 68's analysis
on its own uh changed a lot of people's
minds about anything I think it provided
a critical layer of girding in this
larger narrative structure so that it
could be touted by the Washington Post
and the New York Times and various other
Publications as happened and it was
quoted you know I forget what the the
official somebody did an official tally
it might have been uh Matt taibi but you
know it was quoted thousands of times
times it was written about in glowing
terms not as a partisan ruling party
operation but as a patriotic uh you know
this was a civil defense kind of thing
and and the organization behind it the
alliance for securing democracy which
was created immediately after Trump's
election as an explicitly anti-trump
um operation but in that environment
that people like Brennan helped to
Foster and and legitimize by spreading
this false narrative about Trump Russia
collusion you could create a explicitly
partisan anti-trump organization and
pass it off as a patriotic uh
civic-minded organization because people
it's simply
abdicated their response their their
critical faculties and which is what the
state of exception is intended to
produce so things worked as they were
supposed to work
um and and so I I think that it was both
extremely consequential sort of in the
aggregate effect but um I doubt that
um I doubt that any one Hamilton 68
hashtag analysis accomplished much in
isolation yeah it is kind of fascinating
to think about you know one of the one
of the great fears about Donald Trump as
he remember merged on the scene and
certainly at you know after it became
clear that he had won the election in
2016 was that he was a destroyer of
norms that he was going to wreck
everything that was good and decent
about America about American history Etc
and that his critics time and time again
actually then in the name of preventing
him from destroying norms and and you
know breaking everything actually went
out of their way to do exactly that
um you know by some of the methods that
you're talking about here and eroding
the line between you know an independent
media and state action because you know
with this this is the you know this is
the end of the U.S as we know it if we
don't stop Trump so you know Extreme
Action is warranted it's not merely
you know okay but it's actually the
responsible thing to do you really in a
way the paranoid mentality of you know
what you call the ruling class or the
ruling party
um you have to go back to the Cold War
and you know but then it was a couple of
people in the Republican Party somebody
like Joe McCarthy but it was really nut
jobs like Robert Welch the head of the
John Birch Society who was prone to
these kinds of global overstatements you
know that Dwight Eisenhower the
president who had won World War II who
was fighting the Cold War was a you know
a a winning agent of the Soviet Union he
was sidelined I mean he was considered a
nut job here you see it in plain view an
analysis analogous kind of world view
where your fellow countrymen are not
simply mistaken but they are somehow
either wittingly or unwittingly doing
the bidding again of Russia which is
also kind of fascinating to think about
um I want to ask to complicate just just
a little bit of what you're talking
about or or rather to discuss the way
this played out on social media
particularly Facebook and Twitter which
were the places that you know that both
suppressed the hunter Biden laptop story
but more broadly were accused of pumping
up Trump and then you know on the right
I mean this is one of the reasons why so
many republican members of Congress are
trying to regulate social media because
they keep saying you know we've been
screwed we've been screwed these
companies exist to [__] us over and to
squelch our voices to suppress our reach
and yet throughout you know the teens
and throughout the Trump years Trump and
other conservative voices actually
flourished broadly in the culture but
especially on Facebook and Twitter where
it seemed you know conservative
right-wing people who are the target of
the de-amplification process that you're
talking about and the delegitimation
process actually did really well does
how do you kind of
um you know figure all of that out so I
think that's exactly right and I think
you you have just hit on the impetus
behind this attempt to seize control
over the social media platforms which is
that they benefit the opposition so the
the apparent contradiction is reconciled
by the fact that it is the success of
Donald Trump and these putative uh
populist elements that produces the
counter-reaction in the first place that
leads the ruling party to decide it can
no longer tolerate this degree of
autonomy and needs to clamp down and
effectively take control over the back
end of these platforms they they don't
do it uh they don't do it all at once
they don't simply nationalize the
industries as it were so it's always an
incomplete process and there's always a
space open for
um these now sort of uh you know on
unofficially
illegal is too strong but unofficially
blacklisted parties to still find ways
to prosper and there's an argument to be
made that the technology tends to
benefit them in a kind of structural way
but but this is it's just the the
sequencing is the only the only place
where I would disagree with you so what
I what I trace in the in my essay and
tablet is a chronology in which first
you have the open even bombastic Embrace
as of the internet as a technology of
Liberation and democracy by people like
Donald excuse me not Donald Trump of
course by people like Hillary Clinton
um and uh Barack Obama who are touting
the benefits of social media in
particular as a force for
democratization across the world most
famously in the case of the Arab Spring
but also with protests in Iran
um and Clinton is the the head of the
internet Freedom agenda at the state
department you know one of her aides
famously Compares uh social media to Che
Guevara as a this revolutionary Force
you know very telling like the
platitudes they come up with here you
know
um so so it's these same people the very
same people who then declare the
internet uh the single greatest threat
to democracy what causes this utterly
dramatic 180 where they go from touting
the internet as a great force of
democratization to then declaring that
we we need to enforce martial law on the
internet lest civilization be destroyed
they perceive it as a threat to their
own power and uh continued mandate to
rule and it's as simple as that and they
perceive it as a threat because you have
this growing populist Insurgency you
might call it but really the populist
Insurgency is part of a the populist
Insurgency you know sort of represented
by people like Trump and the brexit
movement in the
ukron I mean you know this is yeah I
mean you point out it's a global
phenomenon and it's it's
multi-determined it is but it's if if it
was simply Donald Trump and Russia
somehow manipulating America you
wouldn't be seeing kind of emanations of
it in various forms all over the place
right we saw that if I may I just wanted
to and I real this is the worst kind of
fan service but I wanted to say to John
McGuire yes that who asked in the
comments this is from a ShopRite
checkout uh from my hometown of
Middletown New Jersey I was visiting her
and the cashier said I could have it
just so we know that sorry and I mean we
saw that that pivot that you're talking
about Jacob from a kind of open Embrace
of the power of the web to democracy and
American Idols to a real threat in the
figure of Hillary Clinton who right
after the election basically introduced
into the Lexicon the concept of fake
news and we have that clip best if you
could just uh pull that up our backstage
is going to play one thread in
particular that should concern all
Americans Democrats Republicans and
independents alike especially those who
serve in our Congress
the epidemic the malicious fake news and
false propaganda that flooded social
media over the past year
it's now clear that so-called fake news
can have real-world consequences
about politics or partisanship
lives are at risk lives of ordinary
people just trying to go about their
days to do their jobs contribute to
their communities
it's a danger that must be addressed and
addressed quickly
so I mean I I do view that as a pretty
important turning point in like modern
American political history that that
speech uh but really you know you as you
document very well in this piece the
machinery for addressing these issues
was starting to be constructed through
in the Obama years around the 2014 era a
lot of this you know as so many things
to do started in our overseas conflicts
with Isis and now have been brought to
the home front could for this latter
half of the conversation here could you
delve a little bit into that history
um and also you know feel free to bring
your personal experience I know that you
were an Army intelligence officer uh and
um just maybe speak to
what happened over there and how it was
transported over here in the intervening
years
yeah so you know what I refer to as the
counter disinformation complex is not
simply an apparatus of censorship and
you know this is one of the really
critical points that I make in this
essay and that I think distinguishes my
analysis from some other people's
analysis including people who I think uh
you know are very insightful but maybe
don't see things quite in the same way I
do the counter disinformation complex
does not exist as sensor it exists to
rule it exists as its own form of
government which is replacing
constitutional democracy and the way
that it's replacing constitutional
democracy is by introducing both new
rules of governance and that's where the
state of exception comes in and then new
technologies of administration so we
could say broadly speaking that the old
rule in America
um was one of self government broadly
speaking or or of a liberal democracy
that favored a pluralistic Outlook in
which the individual was the proper
subject of State protections and that
the the function of the government was
to protect the rights of the individual
within a liberal Democratic framework
and obviously there are revisions to
that in the course of American history
and you know there's a I think a strong
argument that there are a succession of
republics in America right um but but
that was a pretty uh consistent
view of the political system in America
counter disinformation and information
regulation as a a the sort of
foundational philosophical basis of
government just replaces that wholesale
because it declares that the function of
the government is not to protect the
rights of the individual the function of
the government is to protect the
individual and the clients of the
government from external threats and so
it arrogates to itself the sovereignty
that once belonged to the individual
anomaly in order to protect the
individual from these outside threats
but in reality to protect uh protect
their own institutional position and and
try and stay in power
um forever so that's the counter
disinformation complex philosophically
mechanically it consists of two
Parts you might say one part is the
surveillance apparatus and the other
part is the uh as a a sort of outward
facing messaging apparatus so one part
spies on the public and the other part
messages to the public the part that
spies on the public is really born I
mean it's really important during the
Cold War and maybe we'll talk more about
that later but it experiences a sort of
radical growth spurt in the aftermath of
9 11 and during the war on terror and
the critical thing that happens after 9
11. so it very briefly you have the
growth of the security bureaucracy
during the Cold War and that's that
bureaucracy is extremely powerful and
it's extremely important but it does not
have access to all the world's
information it's still running analog
then you have the growth of the internet
which is itself you know in in some ways
a Defense Initiative at its Inception
and
after 9 11
the internet and in particular the the
sort of crucial
internet platforms and and later it'll
be really the social media platforms
begin to operate as direct
adjuncts of the National Security
establishment and we learn a lot of the
uh about this during the from the
Snowden Revelations obviously but some
of it's also happening sort of it's
happening openly it's just hidden in
these sort of
um obscure acts that are that are
redefining what bulk Mass surveillance
looks like in an age where everybody is
pouring more and more information into
these vast data repositories online so
that surveillance apparatus gets built
up during the first decade of the war on
terror more or less and the Bush
Administration they play the critical
role in that that's the Bush
Administration it's their decision to
you know push through the the Patriot
Act it's their decision to suspend
normal constitutional rights so that you
can spy on American citizens or make it
easier to spy on American citizens
that's a Bush Administration initiative
and it's a a Bush Administration of
initiative with bipartisan support I
should say or largely bipartisan support
some push back from people like uh Wyden
and some other people in Congress who
um who voice objections but largely
bipartisan to create this Mass
surveillance apparatus using the
internet
as a way to Hoover up all the
information in the world so that nothing
can get past you because if you recall
in the aftermath of 9 11 what we were
told over and over again was that this
was the result of an intelligence
failure right right and so their
approach to solving the intelligence
failure was not to get smarter it wasn't
that the CIA analysts had failed to
meaningfully connect the dots in a the
sense of deliberate reasoning human
beings who needed to ascertain these
patterns through critical thought no the
thinking was we just didn't collect
literally all the information in the
world and feed it into databases so
that's how we'll solve this problem so
that's the first part the second part
the outward facing messaging part really
gets built up during the Obama
Administration which the Obama
Administration who is who really
introduces the idea of data governance
first of all so Obama has a real feel
for this there's a natural Affinity
between him and the kind of Silicon
Valley people they share some cultural
mores and they sort of understand each
other and they share that technocratic
mindset in an explicit way that
understands
the technology as a platform for social
optimization which you might also call
social engineering
at the same time during the Obama
Administration the surveillance
apparatus and the war on terror
apparatus starts to take on a new role
which is counter messaging so you have
this very critical change where what had
been counter-terrorism enters this new
phase that's called countering violent
extremism cve and this is the growth of
a a new bureaucracy that's focused on
you know Jihadi re-education you might
say and like on its face maybe that's
not such a bad thing you know the the
U.S ran some pretty effective propaganda
campaigns during the Cold War radio for
Europe encounter magazine like they did
some good work there
um encounters a great magazine and it's
not clear that and count encounter is a
great magazine it's not clear it in any
way contributed to the collapse of the
Soviet Union it is it's a great literary
social criticism for sure but absolutely
and it's also it's not like they were
actually a cut out they had funding from
the CIA but
in any event my point is just that you
know you could see a case for the
National Security establishment coming
up with counter Isis uh counter Al Qaeda
messaging in a way that's not
necessarily Sinister and totalitarian in
its implications in this event and what
actually happened to the Obama
Administration was that you built up a
uh cve
counter-terrorism bureaucracy
that utilized the surveillance
methodologies developed during the war
on terror in order to begin
counter messaging these Jihadi groups
while developing the infrastructural and
political framework to legitimize the
idea of mass messaging through
surveillance for non-jihadi groups and
it's a bit hard to trace all of that
Evolution but what I'll say is that the
people who were recruited into cve had
some of the the
Progressive ideological
foundations that maybe made that
transition both are not so difficult and
also appear not nefarious but like a
natural extension of what they were
doing which was improving
um the kind of political hygiene of
people on the internet
um and is this what you are referring to
when you talk about hybrid Warfare this
combination of conventional Warfare with
uh informational Warfare or is there
something more to that term
this would be one of the tactics that
comprises the the sort of assortment of
tactics that Define hybrid Warfare
hybrid Warfare refers to Conventional
and non-conventional means occurring
simultaneously so both over you know
regular uniform troops and irregular
um you know maybe Special Operation
soldiers and civilian uniform
accompanied by a heavy emphasis on
informational and influence operations
also sometimes called fourth generation
Warfare has a sort of similar meaning in
this context absolutely a part of that
and a part of the larger organizational
transformation in the U.S and NATO
defense establishment away from building
up conventional military strength and
towards seeing these informational
operations and these digital or
internet-based aspects of hybrid Warfare
as being essential to the future of
warfare
um and and that that really you know
it's building for a while but that
really becomes the dominant framework
after 2014 when you have this series of
events Russia's invasion of Crimea the
euromaidon movement in Ukraine and the
Isis capture of mosul and Declaration of
its caliphate Northern Iraq all three of
which involve very public
overt social media campaigns that are
you know really sort of
spectacles that are hard to turn away
from even and perhaps most of all Isis
broadcasting its brutality on social
media it is so captivating as a
spectacle that I think it leads uh many
people in the defense establishment to
including you know not that I was part
of the defense establishment but as a
reporter at the time and as a former I
guess I was still in the National Guard
then but as a as somebody who had served
in Iraq in the army
you know I also I think overestimated in
2014 when I was writing about this
including a piece explicitly about
isis's social media campaign where I
quoted Clint Watts on the effect of uh
social media I think I was also
overestimating
how significant this was at a time and a
mistaking
the ability to Captivate attention or to
command attention
um with military efficacy and this is
one of the maybe confusions or
ambiguities inherent in the sort of
attention economy is that we we have a
bias towards overestimating things that
capture our attention yeah this is why
Coney uh you know Coney is gone right
Kony 2012. we solved that because we
recognize it as a problem and then we
ran a lot of hashtag campaigns and put
soldiers in Africa to take care of him
very quickly as we go to the uh of
course the end of this and we definitely
want to talk about where we are and what
what does all of this stuff look like
going forward but just very quickly
Jacob you mentioned a couple of
biographical facts how old are you
I'm 42. okay and you served in Iraq in
2006 and 2007 in Afghanistan in 2012 as
an Army intelligence officer that uh you
know kind of papers over a lot of detail
and Nuance why did you
um why did you serve what was your
um impetus for joining the military
well I was an American and a time when
America was at War and so I thought that
it was my obligation to serve I mean
there were other reasons but probably
none is
um probably none more important than
that did your commitment to Americans
America's kind of foreign policy
establishment or the or the ruling class
in the ruling party establishment come
out of your service intact you know not
your Not Your Love Of America or
anything like that but could you just
talk a little bit about what you saw in
Iraq and Afghanistan and how that
affects how you think about the ways
that you know
um strategies to contain uh you know
Islamic extremism or anti-American
attitudes or anti-democracy and
anti-human rights attitudes
um you know that have now come home you
know what how did your experience change
your appreciation for that
yeah I would say it demolished it
um the demolish the sort of uh Baseline
presumption in the competence and good
intention of the stewards of American
policy
um
which which I held at the same time as I
you know some of the best people I've
ever known in my life were guys I serve
with in the Army so
um
I I had both of those experiences but
you know in Iraq I it's strange to say
because I
it was in a lot more physical danger in
Iraq and I was there during the surge
but
uh sort of because of that I was almost
more of a spectator to the political
aspects of it and you know I should say
I never viewed it as my job to
solve uh the politics of any of this I I
because I took for granted the basic
competence
um
Civic mindedness
um of the leaders the the nation's
leaders I didn't didn't invest too much
time in thinking about it for myself now
I mean I certainly I thought we'd gotten
Iraq very wrong I thought that um things
had gone very wrong I thought that there
was a lot of stupidity and incompetence
and delusion and I probably thought all
that before I even deployed to Iraq I
mean I think by the time I deployed to
Iraq head I already thought all that but
I thought of that in
like decent people making catastrophic
mistakes sort of way not just decent
morally but fundamentally sound people
making catastrophic mistakes in
Afghanistan
where I was in a you know relative terms
uh much safer much safer part of the
country a sort of safer period of the
war less
immediate physical threat
I could see
the sort of
um both the lies of the war and the
um strategic nihilism of the war up
close so I could see the lies of the war
insofar as we were all sending up
reports about the training of the Afghan
security forces that were absurd
um and we had to send up those reports
because it was only by certifying that
the Afghan National Security forces were
trained to a certain degree that we
could sign off that this tranche was
ready to transition which meant that the
U.S could get out of there and and hand
it over though of course what ended up
happening is was you know they those
tranches got transitioned on whatever
timeline was determined by people way
way above my level anyway I should say I
mean I was in infantry battalions the
whole time so I didn't have any access
to any high level anything but uh but I
saw that the way I saw the ways in which
um baked into the reporting and the
public messaging about the war because
of course the public messaging about the
wars we were always going to turn the
corner we only needed another year in
Afghanistan and
um and simultaneously the training of
the Afghan National Security Forces
became the sort of all-important
overriding imperative and I saw that
that was based on deliberate
misrepresentation uh perhaps even more
than delusion at the same time
I witnessed up close this vast
bureaucratic structure created in
Afghanistan State Department agencies
and non-governmental organizations and a
million and one contractors I think
people hear military contractor and they
immediately think Blackwater and
mercenaries but you know the vast
majority of the contractors that the U.S
hires in war zones are folding laundry
preparing food or even even the more
specialized one because those are people
we tend to recruit those are Third
Country Nationals as they're called
their Bangladeshi uh citizens who we
bring in or their their from any number
of countries who we hire in to do these
jobs
then there are you know the the
military
trainer experts or whatever uh civil
Authority experts we brought in to to
teach Afghans about how to structure a
police organization or all of this was
being done in a country that had no
organic coherence from one Province to
another where the idea of the
nation-state was not simply foreign in
the sense that they didn't believe in it
it was foreign in the sense that most
people had never heard of it had no
organic connection to it where the real
lines of connection were drawn along
kinship and Clan and to some extent
ethnicity and religion and and I should
say that all of that also was not hard
to figure out for a reasonably aware
person who took a helicopter ride and
looked at the terrain in Afghanistan
because if you saw what it looked like
and if you understood how physically cut
off and connected these places were from
one another and how that had not been
that had not been bridged by technology
in Afghanistan yet there were not these
globalizing Technologies there even
though cell phones were starting to
become ubiquitous while I was there it
wouldn't have been hard to understand
why somebody in
paktika or Kandahar didn't necessarily
have any direct connection to what was
going on in Kabul so I saw all of that
it was extraordinarily
um you know disillusioning and
disheartening but even when I came back
from Afghanistan
I I saw the war as being
you know and also I I should say all of
that was being done to no strategic
purpose there was no reason to be in
Afghanistan we were there was no vital
strategic interest in remaining in
Afghanistan for two decades and and the
real perversity is that precisely the
bureaucratic waste and void that I'm
describing with programs like opium
eradication that we pumped tens of
millions of dollars into only for opium
yields in Afghanistan to be at their
highest levels as we were leaving all of
that was then that was the true reason
we're in Afghanistan right was to
continue these programs that we had
started and
um and that sort of Machinery that that
the defense establishment lived off of
and that various uh sort of connected
even if quasi
um non-military uh agencies lived off of
that's what we were we were really doing
there and it was just easier to stay
than it was to leave less politically
costly
but even when I left I sort of viewed
that as a horrible waste but I didn't
see it as necessarily
um
speaking to the same conditions that
were endemic across the entire political
system so it was a process of
disillusionment uh thank you for uh
talking about that and you've written uh
deeply and movingly about your military
experience how people should uh look for
your byline scattered you know
particularly a tablet magazine but
elsewhere if we can bring this kind of
back home to where we're going because
you know one of one of the things that
you talk about in the story which I
think is really important is that you
know these kinds of apparatuses
technological cultural consensus making
you know surveillance apparatus and
mentalities and mindsets they get
developed for particular moments in time
sometimes well-intentioned sometimes
effective oftentimes poorly intentioned
and ineffective but then they outlive
you know the the thing that gate you
know that conjured them into being
um can we talk a little bit about now
that the kind of attempts to surveil
information flows and understand you
know what was going on radicalization in
Central Asia and and the Middle East and
whatnot now that that has come home and
it's sitting here
um what are the ways that we kind of
change that so you know how do we make
it more visible and how do we um you
know how do we dismantle uh this type of
apparatus because you know the ruling
party ruling class now tends to be a
kind of Centrist left uh or Centrist
liberal uh perspective there's no reason
to believe if for whatever reason we
become a center-right country again you
know the 80s are reborn and something
like a Reagan Coalition comes into Power
they're not going to be interested in
dismantling this right because they will
be able to use it to maintain their kind
of control what do we do
I do think there's a sort of special
Synergy between
progressivism not liberalism but
progressivism and and techno
surveillance States they they do share
certain
important things in common that sort of
can you talk a little bit about them I
mean is what it what is that is it that
individuals are are stupid or prone to
being you know galled into the wrong
decision so they know yes yes what else
and did faith in the expert Class A
faith in the idea that
things uh converge towards singular
correct
outcomes or decisions that can be
discerned through technical processes
you know so inherent in the sort of
let's call it the original idea of
liberalism was an idea the
incompatibility of ends right and so
liberalism is a
liberalism is a means by which societies
deal with
irreconcilable conflicting differences
and the 30 years difference yeah
different visions of life right I mean
in an American context the point of
politics is not to reach a consensus
it's to create a system by which people
who disagree on very important things
are able to live peacefully
right right yeah and now and you're
saying like in a certain kind of
progressive mentality that's out the
window because no there is a right way
to do this there is a right way to do
that this is moral that anything else is
not right well Nick when it comes to
eradicating white supremacy can there
really be two ways right when it comes
to
um when it comes to the vaccine when it
comes to the entire every live thousands
millions of lives are at risk can there
do we do we really have to
um allow for disagreement over these you
know if genocide is on the table or mass
extermination is on the table we have no
time for this so yeah I I but I but I
that's a quibble I agree with 95 of what
you said and I agree that you could
easily see a center right
um government making great use of all of
this while also subscribing to someone
those same sort of progressive
technocratic underlying ideas
um sort of or premises
um
look in terms of what we do about it
um I leave that to others for the most
part my own feeling is that there's too
much and it's too big and
um
you know we need decentralization we
need there's just it's not Global
Information dominance is not something
where you want to have a more benign or
a more democratic version of Global
Information dominance you don't want
Global Information dominance it is
itself it is the problem not the
application of it or the ideological
superimposition on top of it or or the
corruption of the people running it and
so
I think that uh I think that there's a
pretty good basis for how the United
States should be run in
um
you know not to sound like I'm not an
originalist but I just let's not throw
out the Constitution you know I mean I'm
both not an originalist and I'm also
somebody who feels perfectly comfortable
saying in a non-snarky or or uh
sarcastic way that's not throughout the
Constitution because there is a real
expert-led consensus around the absolute
that the the idea that the first
amendment is obsolete now so
I would say the first amendment is not
Obsolete and we should protect the First
Amendment and
um
but yeah I I beyond that you know I'm um
I would like politics to get sane enough
so that I can go back to writing novels
and not feel like I'm missing anything
you know could I asked Zach uh because
we we talk about this a lot and you know
Jacob I mean your analysis both you know
it captivated both of us and I really
think everybody should read this article
and think it through and I tend to agree
with you know most but Zach you know we
on an almost weekly basis we're often
charting uh you know the the moments
when people are escaping centralized
control and people are able to live
their lives more according to how they
see fit and we talk uh Jacob a lot on
you know this uh show and elsewhere
about things like Bitcoin things like
Noster
um even blue sky but where it seems as
if in many profound ways we are
decentralizing power and information and
whatnot and Zach I'm I'm curious to you
do you agree with uh Jacob's pessimist
some in terms of you know clearly he is
describing something real and that is
governing us but are you as as
pessimistic as he is
um I mean I I take everything he's
saying as a warrant uh if there's not
some kind of counter action
serious counteraction thinking that
things could get really bad in this new
system of governance uh whatever that
exactly is takes shape that it's not
going to be the the America that we all
want to live in uh you know there there
was one audience question that I think
kind of gets to this point
um you know Jacob mentioned
decentralization
um FM here says the internet is the new
printing press the elites are scared
because the people are having access to
information once reserved to a few a
fascinating part of the article that uh
that I I liked from Jacob was that
the kind of history of the internet uh
and we talked a little bit about it
before how it started as this kind of
Defense project uh and but it at the
same time there there's always been the
kind of libertarian Silicon Valley ethos
uh but part of the DNA of the internet
may have been to kind of police social
movements from the very beginning and I
think we're just stuck with the fact of
Technology always being a double-edged
sword and we have to try to use the edge
of the sword that is useful to kind of
undercut the the weapon that would you
know result in oppression and uh I think
decentralization is exactly the way to
think about it and those tools are out
there whether it is uh you know
cryptocurrency just encryption generally
the decentralized networks that are
emerging
are
they have been designed in a way to be
resistant to exactly the kind of at
scale
moderation or manipulation that has
occurred over the past decade that we've
just been talking about
um the question is will enough people
start migrating away from that in time
and I think that is an open question and
it's one that we can help answer by
bringing all these issues to light
because people need to know what's going
on in order to react to it
I think that that's basically right I
mean I I think that the there is a real
Danger from the internet and
up applying this label disinformation
was a way of sort of capturing and
corralling that danger and redirecting
it but the danger from the Internet is
is like the comments are said that it
disrupts this
hierarchy of uh
but you know when you forensic bro
s again
first
sequences of the
were Unborn
kinda objective
and the emerging modern nationalism we
understand it and also very very Wars
and yeah
of of the first pamphlets and monks and
and War originalism which were extension
printing press you know this clue in
formulation is that
is ex certain asparity
conditions of man they they accentuate
and build
heuristics that are inherent to Human
so one act of the human personality gets
magnified and Amplified well another is
attenuated different Technologies work
on different characteristics of the
human we saw how the printing press work
and it went through a very uh very
bloody phase and then led to this
resolution which was liberalism in
effect and and
the attempt to sort of put the genie
back in the bottle that's what this
information is in a sense it's it's the
attempt to put the genie back in the
bottle to recapture the kind of elite
consensus that had previously existed
and had allowed for this top-down
messaging control and which was itself
largely a product of these previous
Technologies television and radio
broadcasts and that simply doesn't exist
anymore that world is gone and we have
to make our way through this new world
without trying to put the genie back in
the bottle right I mean I you know uh I
was thinking as you were talking you
know it took us hundreds of years to get
used to the printing press and what that
meant for human organization and you
know both experimentation and a kind of
developing of radically different ways
of living and then we had to come up
with a way to you know to let people
live more peacefully and you get at
liberalism which is not simply a
political philosophy or structure it's
also it's an attitude towards life and
towards pluralism and tolerance and it
seems in in many ways and and some of my
work I talk a lot about this like we
really only got comfortable in America
with free expression in the very late
1950s uh you know before then you
couldn't even [__] publish Lady
Chatterley's Lover without being sued or
brought into court and you know we
finally settle that and now the internet
comes along and disrupts things even
more so we might be looking at another
you know 500 years of disruption I mean
I certainly hope not and I do I agree
with you that looking at the
disinformation mindset and the hoax you
know that you talk about in your article
um is an attempt to you know it's it's a
sign that the elites are losing control
but they can do a lot of damage right
they're gonna lose in the long run
information maybe doesn't want to be
free but everything escapes the lab and
you know starts doing the individuals
start monkeying around with stuff in all
sorts of ways that is interesting and
you know and ultimately triumphant but
that's the issue the uh you know I guess
the final thing that I want to say and
then maybe we can wrap up but the other
um part of your story which I think uh
listeners should really think about a
lot is you know at the beginning of the
global war on terror and I wrote a piece
and just that came out in the December
2001 issue of Reason about the new Cold
War and it was fascinating to see how
both George Bush but also Donald
Rumsfeld who you know people kind of
forget now because he died and he was
you know uh he was an architect of two
massive failures in American kind of
foreign policy or history both you know
when he was part of the Ford
Administration but especially uh part of
the uh George W Bush Administration he
very much called things you know that
the global war on terror was a new Cold
War and that it was going to help us
Supply us with the national purpose Etc
and rattling around there which I think
a lot of people have forgotten
especially if they don't remember the
cold war is that the Cold War was not
simply about foreign policy it was a
structuring device that influenced every
aspect of American life including the
way the media operated the way it taught
Sports uh you know I mean boys in
America had to learn chess you know in
order to because we we were in an
all-out war against the Soviet Union who
were great at chess we had to learn
classical piano you know like we had to
take them on every aspect of Our Lives
that had seemingly nothing to do with
foreign policy got structured by the
Cold War and Jacob I think you know one
of the things that your article does in
your writing in general does by calling
back to that period it kind of it
reminds us that the global war on terror
is kind of over but it remains a
structuring device that is influencing a
lot of what we do
um without without even realizing
anymore in the same way that the Cold
War and that mentality persisted you
know after the fall of the Soviet Union
and the end of the Cold War I guess
um you know do you want to give a final
statement of
um you know where where are the places
either in history or in in current
events or going on right now where you
see
a bit you know some room for Hope where
we might actually come to terms with
this kind of stuff more quickly and more
efficiently and more peacefully than um
than we might have a hundred or two
hundred years ago
well
um I think that's a brilliant point
about the uh the Cold War as a
structuring device and you know sounds
like you you understood that a few
decades before
um I started to Grapple with it but I I
I think that's very astute and that the
way in which the one
transitioned into the other the way in
which the Cold War transitioned to the
war on terror and the war on terror has
now transitioned into the
um
into the war against disinformation
speaks to how critical that structuring
device is and
um you know one of the one of the things
I realized that with all of these things
I'm usually you know I'm wrong a few
times before I start like groping my way
in a sort of drunken stumble towards
being halfway onto something and you
know when covet first broke out I was
like let's lock Downs now let's lock
down and I and I really thought like ah
this is an opportunity for the state to
do something and be competent and
ironically I was probably too influenced
by right-wing weirdos on online who had
been hyping up the thread of covid at a
moment when the sort of center-left
press was saying it was racist to be
worried about covet and so I was too
swayed by the kind of
um you know like in a technical sense
reactionary thinking and I I just uh
well if the Washington Post is trying to
censor this and these guys are saying
it's the worst thing ever it must be the
worst thing ever and what I what I
learned six months later or probably
more like two months later actually was
any technology of social control
introduced under the pretext of
emergency becomes permanent always it's
a universal rule so lockdowns is a
technology of social control are
introduced in a state of emergency they
will recur this is not the last we've
seen of them any technology of social
control becomes permanent and um that
doesn't really address your question at
all but yeah think of that it's a good
uh it's a good uh but sober note to uh
to end on for sure yes uh and thank you
so much for joining us Jake uh if this
stream has not convinced you to read the
article in full I don't know what will
but please check it out and anything uh
by lined with uh by Jacob Siegel is
definitely worth checking out uh thank
you for joining us today thank you Nick
for the conversation and thanks for
everyone who tuned in we will be back
here next week same time